[Music]
first Friday is back tonight for the
month of May this one will be extra
special because it's beer festival you
can sample more than 35 craft beers
enjoy live music art and so much more
tickets to the Beer Festival start at 35
first Friday runs from 6 to 11 in the
arts district in downtown Las Vegas and
of course it is also Cinco de Mayo the
holiday celebrates Mexico winning the
Battle of puebluff over France in 1862.
there are a number of celebrations
happening around the Valley Water Street
Plaza is going to celebrate with live
music food drinks it's all happening
from five to eight Clark County's Cinco
de Mayo celebration also we'll have live
music and dancing boxing vendors and
activities for the kids that's at Bob
Price park it is also from five to eight
and then you gotta check because so many
local restaurants are having lots of fun
and Mariachi including letties Laura
negretti's joining us live so we'll go
back out to her in a little bit she's
got the Mexican Flair